here's a nice angle question we have  parallel lines a e and FC we have  quadrilateral ABCD such that ba bisects  angle EAD and BC bisects angle FCD if  the measure of angle ABC is equal to 150  degrees what is the measure of angle ADC  how do we solve this problem  draw a line through point B that's  parallel to the lines AE and FC then by  alternate interior angles the top angle  is the same as the green angle and the  bottom angle is the same as the blue  angle  so we have the green and blue angle  together will sum to 150 degrees then in  quadrilateral ABCD we have 150 plus d  plus the green angle plus the blue angle  is equal to 360 degrees this means that  300 plus d is equal to 360 and that  gives the answer D is equal to 60  degrees